[Music]
in case closed news submitted by Fermi
for you
humming a fig tree helped to uncover the
bodies of three missing men a fig fig
tree I'm is it Italy fig tree I don't
know dude it's big season right now yes
dude it's big season right now
hey just has Tiger figs and they only
come out during like a month right now
and they're so freaking good well I'm
doing my Trader Joe's you like do you
like the green ones yeah the Tiger way
that's those are yellow with green
stripes
yeah killing myself with boredom yeah
you ain't never had a fig then yeah my
bad
you don't like tiger fig season
everybody
whoopty [ __ ] do then you hear a
gunshot five minutes later as I walk
inside
I like figs thank you Joe I like I like
pigs thank you the tiger ones have those
seeds in their [ __ ] no no seeds but yeah
I don't like that it's like I like it
it's like a jail open it up it's like a
[ __ ] plant eating you it's like
nature's do I even eat the skin yeah the
skin is you're supposed it's so good
figs are good with honey I feel like a
Jesus with the pee I click on this video
I hear you guess what everybody it's fig
season I'm clicking on another video the
guys bodies okay okay yeah it is hey
guys dude you know what I look up all
day is like propagating fiddly fig trees
that's what I do I know you do okay so I
like this type of video whose turn your
whole place into an arboretum I never
buy figs though like I've always seen it
just growing on people's yards and I
just grab that oh it's always local
enough yeah I mean there's like always
fig trees in the neighborhood and it's
just dumped all over the floor no one's
like I'm off the floor no I hope I'm
saying like they're wasting because like
people don't pick up okay so there's
this big tree that's right next to like
literally right next
for the fence but Ike it's too high you
gotta get the novelty yeah cuz I'm like
they're right there they're so luscious
but they're like right out of my face
baby this is the word for figs right
there it's just like a succulent good
through thick yellow the yellow figs
Nikki start Nikki's like I'm driving a
car right now and she's like okay so
there's this fig tree I fall asleep we
start going off onto an embankment like
welcome to my house yeah thank you
exactly just wake up Steven though hey
so let me tell you about this thing can
we take a bot can we talk about pickles
alrighty Nikki's like I just learned
Nikki's like I just learned how to
irrigate irrigate our [ __ ] garden
crops and I'm like you know what your
balls are like two figs figs stripes I'm
in an NPR show right now when I buy a
fruit farm you could come over and look
at the oh just say farmers market six
more times guys before the ad break you
know about fig beetles the [ __ ] do
you know about the big an ability good I
don't know the scientific names I am
well are they yellow or are they black I
don't know
anyway that was the story here so this
takes place from the island of Cyprus
and we're there's a lot of pigs I don't
know if there's a lot of fish yeah
because like that's a Mediterranean area
Cyprus and like Greg and like all those
that's just the de Jesus area but where
this particular fig tree was found there
if that was like the only one the only
one of that type of thing so that tree
was feeding off the dead bodies yeah and
then you guys are eating that [ __ ] you
guys like that's like like food that's
what I want to do though do I want to
die and then when I die I want I want to
be planted I want to tree to be planted
in myself and I want that tree to grow
from me when I want
children eat me you know what happening
with this day so they're saying here
like the whole story here that went
viral was the fact that that this guy
named I met who went missing in 1974
over 40 years ago his family have been
trying to find them finally there was
this man who was part of the missing
like trying to find missing persons
because around that time there was war
and there was a lot of people that went
missing and then they he ended up
finding this fig tree that didn't really
belong there it compared to the rest of
the landscape and it was like this
particular fig - that doesn't naturally
grow there so then he ended up what a
[ __ ] nerd
he ended up digging under the roots to
figure out like where this tree come
from and then there's they initially
were claiming that that's when they
found a body in three bodies and that
one of the bodies this tree was growing
at exactly this guy he ain't a fig in
the seat a fig in the seed no shut up we
really thought they're reporting it
murder was uncovered by a [ __ ] dweeb
it's like your mom telling you if you
swallowed that watermelon seed you're
gonna roll watermelon in you yeah though
they're cleaving who's claiming it the
family of Ahmed little treat me why
the fig tree and then this is the person
who discover and then here's like a bud
like his thinking face so the family
claimed that there are these scientists
are they botanist so what happened was
that they found these bodies and it was
near the fig tree and so like the family
that's still around like they gave like
DNA tests to determine that that was the
brother that went missing and so in
their own mind like the way that they're
being reporting it the is that for them
it gives them closure knowing that they
created a fable to pass on because that
particular type of fig grows in their
home or what he could have done is like
had a backpack and then he died and in
the backpack had the fig it was that
doesn't give the family closure it has
to be in his stomach they're saying that
he ate the fig that came from his home
and that but in reality what they're
saying is that these bodies were found
metres away from the trees where is the
street it's not it's by their home no so
that this type of tree there are so many
fits like from their region or something
where they so he probably does they have
that tree in their home the probably
just ate the fig or whatever like
through it and then kept walking when in
cave the cave got exploded from the
dynamite and then they died he died I
see oh I thought he died because he was
gonna pick a [ __ ] fig and his wife is
with him and like this [ __ ] fig sees
it yeah we got boarded up died in
[ __ ] wither
yeah problem she stayed and eat the figs
next to him until the big tree grew yes
she's telling him a story about a fig
tree and she withered to death aboard a
painting man every boat at the tiger
I cannot take it anymore I've never seen
a fig seed you do see a little bit
inside that all feeds you're eating to
survive in your belly
no that's all fable oh yeah they can
joke the fable that it grew out of
because of because of the dynamite
exploding the cave sunlight came through
the cave and has immense decomposing
body that's how the seed was able to
grow and that's my dream though basic
science everybody if you don't know
about basic science maybe you don't
wanna be on this video obviously basic
stuff yeah carried it with him inside
his belly
that's what the family actually wants to
believe yeah you know you can make
cyanide with apple seeds yeah a lot of
it though it takes a lot have you ever
heard of that is that torture method I
think it's a Chinese torture method
where they wouldn't know where like they
tie you down to where a bamboo was
planted in the ground and then the
bamboo grows through your body until you
die oh wow I heard about that that's
pretty safe that is [ __ ] awesome have
you ever had the Bali coffee colony's
coffee they there's this like specific
monkey do do coffee no like where the
animals eat the beans and [ __ ] them out
and then they made coffee from it but
it's supposed to be like the best coffee
we have one in catch it one - I feel
like it's just like they can't believe
they got tourists to drink [ __ ] exactly
laughs in the back room as you guys
drink it and pay expensive money for I
hope they wash it they'll try to get you
to go there but whatever they say for
the cat is like the digestive enzymes
just something through the coffee beans
and we there's literally one in
Silverlake and I walked by is like this
is the funniest thing I've ever seen in
my life great so they just scoop the
cat's poop and then they just pick out
the beans I don't know I might do a
video on it and foods
I hope they wash it though simples yes
includes do make Timmy eat it but don't
home because you won't know if you don't
tell me it's not like a sibling thing
like we drink a lot so no have you tried
um recently I tried the steak with
coffee grinds on it it's [ __ ] good I
was like baked with coffee grinds wait
because I adds like this like smoky like
deep flavor to it so like people will do
you know like like cowboy steaks will
then put like a chili crust on it
they'll do like coffee grinds and chili
and they'll crust it yeah I know as like
this like deep flavor to it was good Oh
where'd you tell it was at the Delano MA
I forgot the name of the restaurant but
it's like downstairs coffee steaks
coffee grinds in curry when they make it
yeah dude that's like male with
chocolate in it obviously because that's
was part of it but I'm like yo I can't
hang with this bro right it's too dark
it's just 2d I don't know that's the
taste is to be there yeah start to
bitter I liked it I liked the one that
you made that was pretty good okay but I
didn't like love it I was like oh I
gotta get this whole time holy it's so
[ __ ] wild
like when you go to those like play
stats like specify that the rotten corn
no it's just like 4,000 different [ __ ]
in there and they keep rotating it over
so you're eating mole egg that
technically is like 30 your [ __ ]
garbage oh my god yeah okay like
sourdough when they use like the mother
yeah that kind of stuff but they
literally had that same mole in the add
new ingredients new so the flavor always
grows and constantly changes so that's
like the magic of mole and that better
be a C restaurant-grade see you there's
a few spots there's a spot in LA that
does suffice and that a guy that went to
that area in Mexico where they do bowl a
and he took that and he started making
his own and just after years it starts
to intensify in flavor so you'll see
that's like the special thing about mole
a mole a is literally you don't you know
what's in it but you don't at the same
time because it just starts to grow
people add new things to it over and
over for a human body parts in eyes what
are they adding is more chocolate a
chance like there's like there's like
corn and there spices herbs everything
and then it's like boy so every Friday
it's at all today is the day to add more
ingredients to them yeah so it'll go
jump because people will you know
whatever they eat they've got the add
more and it just keeps transforming over
in oh wow
like you said it's like sourdough yeah
there's like a broth in Japan that's
been going on for 70 years
damn like non-stop its Odin broth oh
really
that [ __ ] must be delicious I don't know
about that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]